Okay, I want to tell you a story about a
factory that taught itself how to
remember.
Hi, I'm Rushabh. I run Machinecraft, a
100 people factory in India.
No data science team, no ML budget, none
of that. And somehow we ended up
building a 36 AI agent that runs our
entire go-to-market. I think that's
still a little ridiculous. Let me show
you how it happened and why you can do
the same thing.
So, here's the thing about our company.
From the outside it looks like machines
and metal.
But the actual company, the part that
matters, isn't the machines, it's the
knowledge.
Who the customer is, what we quoted them
in 2019, why that one machine needed
that weird custom tweak. And for three
generations, all of that lived in
exactly three brains. Initially my
grandfather's, then my father's, and now
mine.
Which is a genuinely terrifying way to
run a company.
When you sit with it.
A lot of people have joined us, people
have left us, the revolving door never
stopped.
And every single time someone walked
out, a chunk of our brain
walked out with them.
We weren't scared of the competitors, we
were scared of forgetting.
Or waking up one day and realizing the
whole company only existed inside two
increasingly tired heads.
So, I had an idea.
I'll be honest.
Sounded insane first.
But what if instead of writing the
knowledge down in some document nobody
ever reads,
what if we grew a brain
that just held it?
Not a chatbot you poke at,
a twin of the company.
I didn't hire a sales team.
I tried to build one.
A quick detour
because you need to know how messy this
is.
We make thermoforming machines. They
heat up a plastic sheet and shape it.
Same core machine, but it ends up making
hydroponic farm trays, spa bathtubs, EV
car panels, medical casings, and even
packaging.
Seven totally different worlds, seven
totally different buyers.
So, this brain couldn't just memorize a
brochure.
It had to know which universe
a given customer lives in.
Step one was almost boringly simple.
Feed it everything, and I mean
everything.
Years of quotes, drawings, payment
schedules, timelines, email threads,
hundreds of gigabytes of our own private
history.
Not the public internet, our internet.
And here's the plot twist.
The part that surprises every engineer I
tell this to.
We never trained a model. No GPUs
humming in the basement, no fine-tuning.
We just looked at all the history,
chopped it into bite-size chunks, and
let off-the-shelf models read it and
pull out the facts.
We stored the meaning of each chunk as
vectors and relationships.
Who's connected to what as a graph.
The brain isn't a smarter model. It's
actually a really, really well-organized
memory.
Now,
this is where it gets a little weird in
a good way.
We stopped thinking of Era as a software
and started thinking of it as something
we were raising.
So, we gave it a body modeled on
biology.
Senses to figure out who it's talking
to, a gut to digest the documents into
facts, a memory, a dream cycle, an
immune system to fight off bad
information.
Why biology? Well, because evolution
already spent a billion years solving
how do you stay coherent over time?
We just copied the homework.
Okay, so the big question.
Why 36 agents instead of one genius mega
prompt? Because, and you already know
this if you've ever tried it, one prompt
that's supposed to do everything ends up
doing everything badly. So, Ira isn't
one mind, it's a pantheon. A whole cast
of specialists.
Each one has exactly one job. Athena
runs the room. Prometheus owns the sale.
Plutus does pricing.
Hephaestus knows every machine spec
cold.
Vera fact checks everything, and Memnon,
my favorite, guards corrections. So, the
second a human fixes something, it stays
fixed forever.
One agent, one job. It's a team, not a
hero.
And here's the cool part. They hold
meetings. Athena pulls in specialists.
They actually argue, and a single answer
comes out the other side.
It's like having a board room that never
sleeps, never gets tired, and somehow
has no ego.
So, what does all this actually run?
Honestly, the whole front business.
Everything between a stranger exists
somewhere, and now they're a customer.
Nine concrete jobs every single day.
Outbound emails that actually reference
my real world. Account briefs built from
cross-checked truths before a call.
Quotations. A swipe left, swipe right
mode
for outreach. Reviving dead leads, which
I call blast from the past.
Inbound replies, and figuring out before
we waste an hour whether a company is
even a fit.
Nine jobs, one operator who never
sleeps.
Where does all this live?
One cursor tab. That's genuinely it. You
type and Eira reaches out with a dozen
hands.
Searches the knowledge base, reads the
inbox, drafts the email, builds the
code, and then shows you before anything
actually goes out.
Under the hood, it's genuinely a real
stack. Not a demo held together with
duct tape.
Databases for vectors, for relationship
graph, for the CRM.
Three different model providers, each
picked for the job it's actually best
for. Tools for Google, for swallowing
documents, for every communication
channel, plus monitoring. So, we can see
what it's thinking.
All of it, every capability exposed as
213 tools over one protocol.
And the golden rule, the one we never
break, Eira drafts, human sends.
Now, memory. And this is the part where
most AI quietly lies to you, because a
raw language model is basically a
goldfish. Brilliant for about 30
seconds, and then you close the tab and
forgets you ever existed.
So, we engineered memory on purpose, in
layers.
Working memory for the last few minutes.
Pinned facts about someone who who is.
Episodes, whole conversations as little
stories. Relationships with warmth that
grows
from stranger to trusted.
And a bouncer at the door.
A salience gate that decides what's even
worth remembering, so the brain doesn't
fill up with junk.
When two facts disagree, corrections
win.
Continuity without making things up.
And then, I genuinely love this part. At
night, it dreams.
Every night, Eira runs a sleep cycle. It
replays the day, locks in useful stuff,
hunts for contradictions,
gently forgets the stale junk, and turns
the day's work into reusable skills.
In the morning, there's a little dream
report waiting for me to read.
Here's what I consolidated. Here's what
I Here's what I let go of. Here's what I
figured out while you were asleep. The
thing
literally gets smarter overnight.
And here's the part I care about the
most. Every agent has a conscience. And
it is
emphatically not to be helpful, be
harmless. It's a soul file
written from the principles of a Jain
family business that's been doing this
for the last three generations.
Five old ideas turn into engineering
rules.
No single source has the whole truth.
So, cross-check before you speak.
Never say things absolutely. Cite the
document and the date.
Do your own job, not someone else's.
Report the truth even when the truth is
ugly. And nobody works alone. Ancient
philosophy running as guardrails in
production.
Now, let's talk money. Because this is
the part that should make the whole
industry a little uncomfortable.
There was no training bill. Zero.
The expensive part was never compute. It
was teaching a company to remember
itself.
An agency quoted us 230 grand to build
this.
We built it for around 30.
That's cheaper than a nice watch.
And it runs on a couple of thousand
dollars a month.
So, here's the move.
We pulled the whole architecture out and
made it forkable.
We call it Brain OS. It ships as an
empty nervous system. The agents, the
memory, the dream cycle, the soul file.
All there, completely blank. You pour
your own company's truth into it and
from inside out.
Because here's the thing nobody can
outsource for you.
Only you can build your company's brain.
We are a 100 people factory with no data
scientists. If we can grow a brain, you
can too.
We are not selling ours to you. We are
helping you build your own.
forkmybrain.org
Go build something that remembers.
Thank you.